wir sind wieder für euch zdf heute live
schön dass wir bei uns im stream seid ja
es gibt sie neue militär und
waffenlieferungen aus dem westen für die
ukraine das hat heute die sogenannte
ukraine kontaktgruppe auf der airbase
ramstein in rheinland-pfalz beschlossen
unter anderem gibt's dann waffenpaket
der usa für die ukraine mit einem
volumen von rund
675 millionen dollar was aber noch
konkret weiteres beschlossen wird und
wie das der ukraine helfen kann das
sortieren wir gleich alles schritt für
schritt für euch über allem steht
natürlich auch die frage bringt das
womöglich die wende in diesem krieg ist
putin womöglich jetzt in der defensive
antworten darauf bekommen wir heute von
militärexperte markus kolb von der
militärakademie der eidgenössischen
technischen hochschule in zürich und von
unserer ukraine korrespondentin katrin
eigendorf sie ist für uns vor ort in
khaki fragen von euch sehr gerne direkt
in die chats oder hier eingeblendet die
mailadresse zdf live at zdf.de wir
freuen uns auf eure beteiligung
falls ihr euch jetzt gerade aber nochmal
fragt moment mal wer hat sich da jetzt
genau wo getroffen und was genau wurde
da jetzt beschlossenen thomas reichert
fast für uns das treffen auf der airbase
in ramstein noch mal zusammen heißt die
amerikanische verteidigungsminister in
ramstein landet hat er zwei dinge dabei
das versprechen neuer waffenlieferungen
an die ukraine im wert von über 6 175
millionen dollar und die forderung an
europa sich vorzubereiten dass die hilfe
für die ukraine noch sehr lange dauern
wird
heute muss diese kontaktgruppe zeigen
dass sie die ukraine langfristig
unterstützen will und das bedeutet den
kontinuierlichen und entschlossenen
fluss von militärischen fähigkeiten
die usa kündigen deshalb weitere
lieferungen von artilleriemunition um
die ukraine bei ihrer gegenoffensive zu
unterstützen deutschland verspricht
helfen unter anderem bei der
minenräumung aber es bleibt beim nein
der regierung zur lieferung von
schützen- oder leopard panzern die in
deutschland bereit stünden panzer sollen
andere liefern
und es ist ganz wichtig dass wir die
ukraine schnellstmöglich unterstützen
deswegen gehen wir den weg dass wir die
länder bitten abzugeben was sie haben
aus beständen sowjetischer bauart damit
eben schnell damit gekämpft werden kann
das ist der schwerpunkt und wir helfen
dann beim auffüllen von entstehenden
lücken bei einem überraschungsbesuch im
kia verspricht auch us-außenminister
blinken heute helfen im kampf gegen
russland 2,2 milliarden dollar für die
ukraine und andere osteuropäische
staaten
das gesicht des krieges verändert sich
und damit auch die aufgabe dieser
kontaktgruppe sie werden
zusammenarbeiten und die ukrainischen
streitkräfte für die langstrecke
auszubilden ob allerdings auch europa
diesen langen atem hat das wird sich
erst noch zeigen müssen
also wir haben es gesehen zwei
beschlossen eine umfangreiche pakete
markus kolb von der militärakademie der
eth in zürich ist jetzt bei uns schönen
guten abend herr kolb vielen dank
erstmal für ihre zeit direkt die
wichtigste frage aus ihrer einschätzung
bringen diese hilfeleistung diese
beschlossenen jetzt die erhoffte wende
hallo genannt er die wende ist
eigentlich schon eingetreten mit den
letzten waffenlieferungen also vor allem
mit der schweren und mobilen ar theorie
den heim aus system mit denen es
demokraten gelungen ist die russische
logistik weiträumig auszuschalten das
jetzt verkündete paket also das von
heute setzt jetzt stärker auf mobilität
das heißt also dass steht damit in
zusammenhang dass der krieg wieder zum
bewegungs krieg wird wie wir in den
letzten zwei tagen gesehen haben und da
passt das jetzt sehr gut hinein sie
haben auch gesagt dass es wichtig ist im
vorgespräch über die ukrainische
operation zu sprechen und auch dass die
pakete die beschlossen werden
zielgerichtet angepasst werden aus ihrer
sicht ist das so und wie ist da gerade
der aktuelle stand ja das ist so man
muss einfach verstehen wir reden hier
nicht vom zweiten weltkrieg wo eine
gegenoffensive entlang
großen front mit viel personal und viel
material passt jetzt sondern es ist ein
krieg der sich in der operationsführung
gegen die russiche logistik richtet das
ziel der operationen die wir jetzt sehen
im kopf ist die stadt koblenz das ist
mit abstand der wichtigste
eisenbahnknoten für die ganze front für
die ganzen frontabschnitt von silvia
wäre donetsk und dort unten steht eine
erhebliche angriffs teil der russen
ungefähr 20 bataillone seit dem mai die
sind dort unten stecken geblieben beim
angriff auf
sowie angst und sind abhängig von dieser
versorgung autos kopien scalzo spricht
wenn die eisenbahn nicht kommt von
koblenz herunter nach ist jung entstehen
die da ohne logistik und die ukraine
rücken im moment vor und versuchen diese
eisenbahnlinien zu unterbrechen es geht
deutlich schneller als viele erwartet
haben sie stehen im moment noch zehn
kilometer vor cairns das heißt also
nicht nur in athen reichweite sondern
sie könnten sogar in die stadt einrücken
die eisenbahnlinien unterbinden und
damit die russische logistik zerstören
das heißt diese truppen im raum ist jung
stehen dann ohne logistik da ja wichtige
erste erklärungen davon markus kolb der
den aktuellen kriegs dann nochmal für
uns zusammengefasst hat vielen dank bis
hierhin wir sprechen natürlich gleich
noch mit ihnen weitergehen jetzt aber
direkt rüber zu unserer korrespondentin
katrin eigendorf sie ist für uns in
relativ da läuft aktuell südlich von
kiew auch eine gegenoffensive der
ukrainischen armee und katrin eigendorf
sie ist in der stadt selbst in rackith
vor ort mit ihrem team katrin wir sehen
dich jetzt auch gerade schon schönen
guten abend erst mal an dich was erlebt
ihr etwas erlebst du in der stadt selbst
gerade
guten abend nach mainz wie man das
vielleicht hinter mir sehen kann die
stadt und wir sind hier mitten im
zentrum ist fast komplett dunkel man
fürchtet hier jederzeit russische
angriffe wir haben auch gerade wieder
hier einen alarm gehabt deswegen machen
wir hier auch kein wirklich starkes
licht an damit wenig die aufmerksamkeit
auf uns ziehen also die bewohner hier
rechnen permanent mit angriffen alleine
heute morgen sind bei einem russischen
angriff wieder zwei menschen getötet
worden die situation hat sich hier
deutlich verschärft die stadt als wir
heute nachmittag hier angekommen waren
war fast wie ausgestorben wir sind hier
in einem riesen hotel die einzigen gäste
nur zehn prozent der geschäfte sind noch
geöffnet die schulen sind alle komplett
geschlossen und auf online unterricht
umgestellt also es findet hier so gut
wie gar kein öffentliches leben im
moment statt das ist die zweitgrößte
stadt der ukraine hier im osten ganz nah
an der russischen grenze sie steht auch
im fokus weil es den ukrainischen
militärs hier gelungen ist große
geländegewinne
zu verbuchen das war heute auch die
große meldung in kiew mit der see lenski
wieder an die öffentlichkeit gegangen
ist ich denke man hat das natürlich auch
noch mal besonders herausgestellt weil
man den internationalen partnern und den
ländern die die ukraine hier weiter mit
waffen unterstützen sollen klar machen
will ja man kann eine wende herbeiführen
wenn man entsprechende militärische
unterstützung bekommt
was kannst du uns vielleicht zum
aktuellen stand auch der offensive
südlich von euch sagen die du gerade
angesprochen als wie ist da der stand
also es ergibt sich hier ein
differenziertes bild wir haben es einmal
im nördlichen don was mit einer
situation zu tun wo es den ukrainern
gelangen gelungen ist wirklich den
russischen vormarsch aufzuhalten ist
sehr kurze zeit so aus als ob es den
russen gelingen würde den kompletten die
kompletten regionen dann jetzt und
lugansk zu erobern hier haben die
ukraine deutliche gewinne erzielt was
aber ganz besonders interessant ist die
lage im süden der ukraine wo ist
gelungen ist nachschubwege wir haben das
ja vorhin schon gehört auch im beitrag
bei der analyse des militärexperten
nachschubwege abzuschneiden interessant
ist hier die situation im moment denn
der chef des russischen des ukrainischen
generalstabs hat erstmals einen artikel
veröffentlicht in dem er ziemlich genau
beschrieben hat wie die strategie der
ukraine aussieht also es ist überhaupt
keine rede mehr davon bestimmte
territorien aufzugeben oder etwa den
russen zu überlassen sondern ist ganz
klar die strategie alle gebiete
inklusive der krim zurück erobern zu
wollen
damit dort auch im prinzip keine
möglichkeit mehr für die russische armee
ist von dort aus angriffe durchzuführen
zum ersten mal hat die ukrainische seite
ja auch zugegeben dass sie angriffe auf
der krim durchgeführt hat das mag ja
bisher im verborgenen
was auch eine entscheidende neuigkeit
ist ist dass man klar eine perspektive
gegeben hat dass dieser krieg so bald
nicht enden wird sondern
im prinzip wird die ukraine die
ukrainische regierung nicht nur die
eigene bevölkerung sondern auch ja ihre
unterstützer im westen darauf ein dass
dieser krieg ins nächste jahr gehen wird
und dass eine verhandlungs perspektive
aus ukrainischer sicht ja eigentlich
nicht da ist ich hatte gestern
gelegenheit mit dem berater von
präsident selensky ein längeres gespräch
zu führen und der hat das noch einmal
erläutert und gesagt russland kann nur
militärisch besiegt werden erst wenn es
gelungen ist russland so weit zu kriegen
dass das land nicht mehr in der lage ist
krieg zu führen gegen seine nachbarn
dann ist der moment gekommen wo man sich
an den verhandlungstisch setzen kann
braucht man nicht ein militärexperte
zusammen um sich vorzustellen dass eine
solche wende nicht in wenigen monaten
oder wochen gar herbeizuführen ist
selbst wenn man das was im moment hier
am boden passiert als erstaunlichen
nicht erwartbaren fortschritt der
ukraine sehen kann ein wichtiger
baustein das wird auch von seiten der
ukraine wie immer wieder genannt sind
waffenlieferungen aus dem westen
parallel zu dem was du gerade erlebt gab
es ja eben auch heute das treffen der
kontaktgruppe in ramstein und da wurden
hilfen beschlossen haben wir schon
gehört aber vielleicht an dich die frage
wie kommt das auf ukrainischer seite an
und vielleicht auch in der bevölkerung
auf ukrainischer seite gibt es schon
eine reaktion direkt aus dem büro von
präsident sie lenski ein dank an die
internationalen partner allen voran die
usa das kommt natürlich bei der
bevölkerung sehr gut an denen die
ukraine wissen alle dass sie diesen
krieg nur führen und im service fall
auch gewinnen können mit internationaler
unterstützung eben mit waffen aus dem
westen mit auch training und
ausbildungsmöglichkeiten mit humanitärer
hilfe ohne dass wenn die ukraine hier
alleine stehen würde hätte sie natürlich
gegen die militärische überlegenheit
russlands keine chance allerdings sieht
man dass hier in der bevölkerung und
auch in der politik durchaus
differenziert
man sieht deutschland hier in einer doch
etwas kritischen rolle weil viele
ukrainer sind der meinung deutschland
tut eigentlich für die tatsache dass es
ein so großes und wichtiges land ist
nicht genug und der berater des
präsidenten sagte mir gestern in unserem
gespräch so ein bisschen mit bitternis
auch anscheinend hat die deutsche
öffentlichkeit immer noch nicht
verstanden worum es hier in diesem krieg
geht es um viel mehr geht als um die
frage der existenz der ukraine sondern
um die frage ja wird ein totalitärer
staat wie russland künftig agieren
können wie er will oder ist die
internationale gemeinschaft der westen
fähig und in der lage
russland in die schranken zu weisen
militärisch auf die rolle deutschlands
kommen wir natürlich auch noch im
weiteren verlauf des streams zu sprechen
was da konkret auch von ukrainischer
seite gefordert wird das hast du katrin
gerade schon mal angesprochen vielleicht
bleiben wir auch noch mal bei der
ukrainischen bevölkerung auch mit blick
auf die nächsten wochen monate mit blick
auf den winter ist auch ein thema im
chat was hörst du da wie zufrieden ist
man damit der ausstattung und auch der
hilfeleistung aus dem besten in sachen
schutzausrüstung vielleicht auch
ja das ist ein großes thema in den
sozialen medien und das richter richtet
sich die kritik nicht nur gegen den
westen sondern auch gegen die eigene
regierung es gibt immer mehr soldaten
die zwar nicht öffentlich aber zumindest
in chat gruppen davon sprechen dass sie
nicht genügend ausrüstung haben dass sie
an der front nicht mit genügend warme
kleidung versorgt werden das teilweise
freunde und das weiß ich selber aus
meinem ukrainischen bekanntenkreis geld
sammeln dafür dass ihre bekannten und
verwandten an der front vernünftig
versorgt werden also da gibt es doch
deutliche lücken wenn man dem glauben
darf was menschen hier erzählen und was
auch in den sozialen medien herum geht
niemand äußert diese kritik im moment
offiziell weil wir sind hier im land im
moment in einer situation wo jede form
von kritik an diesem krieg und kritik an
der regierung ja im prinzip nicht
opportun scheint und sofort eigentlich
ja niedergeschlagen wird das heißt im
prinzip ist die ganze bevölkerung in
diesem modus wir müssen jetzt diesen
krieg durchführen gewinnen keine kritik
an der regierung aber es rumort schon
doch in bestimmten kreisen der soldaten
vor allem die freiwilligen die sich hier
in territorial verbänden freiwillig
gemeldet haben um die sicherheit ihrer
städte oder auch gewisse infrastruktur
objekte sicherzustellen die sind
besonders schlecht ausgerüstet da sind
natürlich wie gesagt nicht die
erwartungen allein an den westen sondern
auch an die eigene regierung das meer im
blick zu haben sehr sehr groß
katrin eigendorf für uns in der ukraine
vor ort in vielen dank dass du heute die
zeit für uns hat es und auch nochmal
diese einschätzung geliefert hat
dankeschön nachhaken
wir machen weiter und vertiefen die
situation mit markus kolb von der
militärakademie der eth in zürich
fasst noch einmal zusammen es gibt neue
hilfspakete mit neuen waffen und auch
beschlossenen panzern für die ukraine
sie selbst haben auch gerade angedeutet
dass eine wende womöglich gerade
eingeleitet werden könnte putin versucht
aktuell auf der anderen seite aber auch
ein anderes bild zu präsentieren
vielleicht auch natürlich schon die
ganze zeit mit einem informationstag
nach us-informationen will russland
jetzt offenbar raketen und auch
artillerie munition aus nordkorea
beschaffen es könnte sich dabei zitat um
millionen von munition raketen und auch
granaten handeln heißt es da aus dem
weißen haus also auf der einen seite
eben diese bilder die wir gerade sehen
aber auf der anderen seite dann eben
doch die information der blick russlands
nach nordkorea weil die eigenen munition
offenbar nicht mehr ausreichend herr
kolb frage an sie geht putin da langsam
die puste aus
nordkorea ist immer für einen spaß gut
am besten nähert man sich diesen
informationskrieg indem man einfach mal
die logistik durchrechnet und dann kommt
man relativ schnell darauf wie absurd
dieser gedanke eigentlich ist also
nehmen wir mal an dass die sowjetischen
munitionsdepots tatsächlich allmählich
leer geschossen sind nehmen wir an dass
die russische rüstungsindustrie nicht
nachliefern kann also gehen sie jetzt
nach nordkorea und versuchen die feuer
intensität die sie in der ukraine haben
aufrecht zu erhalten also nehmen wir zum
beispiel nur mal die donbass front ist
in den juli hat russland ungefähr 50.000
artilleriegranaten pro tag verschlossen
also sie können sich vorstellen die
front steht 24 stunden unter dauerfeuer
jetzt wenn wir das mal durchrechnen und
wir nehmen mal eine eine mittelschwere
artilleriegranate 52 kilogramm also
solche die noch in den leichten
haubitzen geladen werden können ohne
mechanische doppel dann sind wir bei
einer menge von 50.000 mal 50 kilogramm
pro tag also mit anderen worten 2500
tonnen allein artilleriegranaten das ist
ungefähr ein mittelschwerer güterzug
wenn sie sich jetzt überlegen wie kommt
das dann eigentlich von nordkorea an die
front also eh demokrat nordkorea hat die
gleiche spurweite wie wir also
europäische normalspur china übrigens
auch russland hat aber die russische
breitspur das heißt sie brauchen
zunächst mal kompatibilität der systeme
es sei denn sie wollen nicht jeder satz
dann alles um laden aber der wird china
ins match gehen es gibt eine einzige
eisenbahnlinie und zwar von kasan ihnen
den nordkoreanischen bahnhof ratschen
und dort müssten sie also pro tag einen
güterzug von 2.500 tonnen voll beladen
mit artilleriegranaten zur verfügung
stellen und den dann auf die reise
schicken der fährt er nachher oft und
von dort über die transsibirische
eisenbahn zunächst mal in das
europäische russland und von da in die
ukraine also ungefähr
9400 kilometer so ein schwerer güterzug
also ein personenzug auf der transsib
fährt mit ungefähr 70 km/h güterzuges
halt so schnell also rechnen wir ein
bisschen großzügig mit tausenden sind
wir bei zehn bis elf tagen für einen
güterzug und sie brauchen pro tag einen
ich bin gespannt wie nordkorea diese
bahnverkehre organisieren bild also
allein schon wie es seine seine
artilleriegranaten aus den lagerhäusern
oder den fabriken zunächst mal zum
bahnhof bringt und dann in die züge
verlegt und dann einer dieser langen
schweren züge pro tag fährt und was
machen dann eigentlich die personenzüge
auf der transsib müssen die dann warten
also sie sehen hier je länger man
darüber nachdenkt desto mehr fällt
dieses konzept auseinander und ich warte
das übrigens immer ich weiß nicht also
die deutschen scheinen sehr anfällig zu
sein diesen propaganda geschichten die
man auf den leim zu gehen ich hatte
immer dazu einfach die logistik mal
durch zu richten es war genau so werde
bei der angeblichen welt hungersnot
weiter geht es über die ukraine jetzt
kein getreide exportieren kann sie
können jede russische propaganda
geschichte nach der methode
durchleuchten und sie merken relativ
schnell wie absurd das eigentlich ist
jetzt einmal aktuell ja auch noch dazu
kommt dass putin in dieser woche eine
rede gehalten hat wo er ja sogar
teilweise
eingestanden hat dass die westlichen
sanktionen greifen und sich auch und die
aussage getätigt hat nordsee mainz bei
so lange geschlossen bis ihr also der
westen die sanktionen zurück nehmt
verwundert da auch dieses eingeständnis
aus ihrer sicht und bröckelte auch
putins strategie irgendwie dieses bild
propaganda und stärke nach außen zu
demonstrieren ja ich fand es schon
ungewöhnlich weil es das eigentliche
russische propaganda narrativ
durchbrochen hat also dass russlands am
2 september trotzdem eins geschlossen
hat dabei ja zunächst mal die übliche
propaganda geschichte der westen ist
schuld weil aufgrund der bösen
westlichen sanktionen können wir leider
leider die turbinen nicht mehr warten
oder leider leider tritt der öl aus und
deswegen müssen wir das aus
sicherheitsgründen abschalten lala also
es wurden technische gründe vorgeschoben
warum notz dem einsatz angeblich nicht
mehr liefern kann am tag darauf kam aber
ein anderes statement das ist was sie
gerade erwähnen und dann hat putin
gesagt trotzdem eins bleibt so lange
geschlossen bis die westlichen
sanktionen aufgehoben werden so wenn sie
jetzt überlegen dass das russische
narrativ der letzten woche folgendes war
in westlichen sanktionen sind
wirkungslos wir spüren überhaupt nichts
uns geht es super und jetzt stellt das
sich in uns sagt aber erst wenn die
sanktionen aufgehoben werden kriegt ihr
wieder gas
da kann man sich jetzt fragen also
werden die sanktionen dann vielleicht
doch ja also sie sehen dass das passt
nicht zusammen und das ist das ist
ungewöhnlich weil die russische
propaganda war in der vergangenheit
immer sehr sehr in sich geschlossen es
gab eine eine klare geschichte und die
haben sich alle gehalten und putin hat
die zum ersten mal durchbrochen am
dritten september ich weiß nicht ob es
absichtlich gemacht hat oder oder aus
unachtsamkeit aber dass das ist
ungewöhnlich
also auch da ein zeichen dass die
strategie bröckelt vielleicht lassen wir
auch noch mal zusammen besitzen aktuell
zahlenmäßig aus auf seiten ukrainische
und russische armee und dann auch wie
wird sich das entwickeln wenn die
hilfspakete ankommen und wenn auch der
technische stand sich verändert von den
waffen ja
man kann es eigentlich so zusammenfassen
dass zumindest an dem frontabschnitt den
wir jetzt genauer betrachten also hin im
rahmen von kakás position
erkämpft eigentlich das zwanzigste gegen
das einundzwanzigste jahrhundert ich
habe seit märz nichts anderes gesagt es
immer dass das russland diesen krieg
führt aus seinen reserven aus seiner
eigenen rüstungsindustrie das heißt also
mit material das teilweise noch aus
sowjetzeiten stammt teilweise aus dem
modernen russland das heißt also das hat
das technologie niveau der späten 80er
und der 90er jahren die ukraine wird
aber natürlich je länger der krieg
dauert immer stärker mit modernen nato
material ausgerüstet also wir am
attraktivsten sind eben die heim aus
systeme die mit gps koordinaten ihre
raketen abfeuern die also ein treffer
radius von von vier metern haben uns ist
sehr sehr genau treffen und die russen
haben technologisch einfach dem nichts
mehr entgegenzusetzen je länger der
krieg dauert desto mehr sieht man diesen
unterschied in technologie niveau und
genau deswegen sieht die ukraine auch in
der lage die russischen logistischen
strukturen so punktgenau herauszunehmen
also die eine seite besteht darin
zunächst mal zu wissen wo sind zum
beispiel die munitionslager wo sind
wichtige installation wo sind wichtige
eisenbahnlinie das sehen sie aus den
karten oder die partisanen versorgen sie
mit den genauen koordinaten aber dann
kommt es eben darauf an dass sie eine
punktgenaue artillerie haben die diese
koordinaten auftritt am besten hat man
es gesehen bei den brücken über den mini
oper also dass sie wirklich auf
metergenaue distanz straßen oder brücken
ausschalten können und das ist ein
technologisches können was den russen
einfach nicht zur verfügung steht und
das zeigt sich jetzt immer stärker
in kriegsdorf die ukraine bekommen auch
waffen wie zum beispiel die atm 88 mit
der sie die wohl die russische
luftabwehr ausschalten können und das
auch etwas das man verstehen muss bei
der offensive hier am sonntag auf was
sie eben nicht sehen sind irgendwelche
versuche der russin das geflecht der
verbundenen waffen zu führen also zum
beispiel auch nur eine rudimentäre
luftverteidigung zu etablieren verstehen
sie die demokratischen gruppen fahren
einfach durch also man kann nicht mal
mehr von einer front sprechen und es ist
quasi an eine eine tasche die sich
einfach öffnen und dahinter ist nichts
und es zeigt ihnen schon dass die
russische gefechts führung einfach weder
von der operationsführung auch von der
technologie in der lage ist diesen vor
schluss im moment etwas entgegenzusetzen
also das ist das wirklich überraschende
ist es gibt keinerlei air defence die
ukraine kann frei operieren am boden sie
kann frei mit den drohnen in der luft
operieren
das hat glaube ich in dieser form
niemand erwartet also ich am
allerwenigsten
und was würden sie sagen katrin
eigendorf hat das vorher noch
angesprochen zum thema länge des
weiteren verlaufs oder auch wann wird
sich sozusagen
die situation womöglich komplett
umdrehen
ich teile zunächst einmal die sicht des
ukrainischen generalstabs dass dieser
krieg sich bis weit ins jahr 23 ziehen
wird also ich würde sagen er ist
frühestens heute in einem jahr beendet
also september 23 könnten wir mal
vorsichtig darüber sprechen was für den
rest des jahres passieren wird ist die
die kriegführung wie wir sie jetzt sehen
also sprich die russische logistik
möglichst stark zu dezimieren
munitionslager herauszunehmen straßen
und eisenbahnen verbindungen zu
unterbrechen und damit die russischen
truppen jetzt im kommenden winter ohne
versorgung und ohne munition dastehen zu
lassen
es ist möglich dass das besser läuft das
von den ukrainern selbst geplant dass
ich glaube nicht dass ich das sie selbst
gedacht haben dass das jetzt so schnell
geht und die russen in diesem abschnitt
wirklich so so schnell kollabieren geht
es in den letzten 48 stunden gesehen
haben aber diese operationen sind
eigentlich preparing the battle viel zu
sagen die amerikaner dazu also spricht
man versucht erst mal dem gegner
möglichst logistik auszuschalten und
dann die eigentliche rückeroberung des
gebietes zu starten das wird aber dieses
jahr nicht mehr passieren dazu sind
demokratischen reserven im moment zu
gering also die ukraine muss ich selber
erst noch konsolidieren und diese
offensive vorbereiten deswegen bekommt
sie hat er auch laufend weiter diese
waffenlieferungen also wie gesagt wenn
sie das paket von heute anschauen da
sehen sie eben einen leichten schwenk
hin zur mobilität zu leichteren system
zum leichten gepanzerten fahrzeugen und
da merken sie das beginnt jetzt diese
vorbereitung im herbst winter und
vielleicht für den frühjahrs frühjahr
können wir dann größere offensiven auch
im territorialen sinne aber ein
wichtiger aspekt für diese vorbereitung
das wird von ukrainischer seite auch
immer wieder gesagt ist die rolle
deutschlands und das thema deutschland
und die waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
das ist ja seit der krieg in diesem
februar eine neue dimension erreicht hat
sehr komplex sehr vielschichtig
deutschland hat lange sehr zurückhaltend
agiert mittlerweile werden aber waffen
geliefert und welche das sind das
schauen wir uns jetzt mal genauer an und
wieder genau der stand ist das weiß
michael feller
waffen im wert von mehr als 700
millionen euro soviel hat die
bundesregierung der ukraine bisher
genehmigt der großteil bereits geliefert
darunter auch schwere waffen wieder
gepard flugabwehr panzer 20 von ihnen
hat die ukraine bereits erhalten aus
beständen der deutschen industrie 30
sollen es laut bundesregierung werden
inklusive circa 6.000 schuss munition
den von der ukraine besonders
gewünschten leopard 2 panzer hat die
bundesregierung bislang nicht zur
verfügung gestellt angekommen sind
hingegen schon schwerer artillerie
geschütze wie 10 panzerhaubitzen 2000
weitere 100 dürfen neu für die ukraine
hergestellt werden diese sollen aber
erst ab 2024 geliefert werden bereits
angekommen sind drei mehrfach
raketenwerfer vom typ mast 2
damit können etwa gps gelenkte raketen
verschossen werden
neben schweren liefert deutschland auch
leichtere waffen wie maschinengewehre
handgranaten und munition
außerdem helle bekleidung kraftfahrzeuge
zelte und vieles mehr
herr kolb haben wir immer den überblick
bekommen und ein aspekt gerade ich mal
raus denn wenn nämlich auch bei uns
gefragt hier per mail christiane more
fragt stichwort leopard 2 kampfpanzer
warum werden denn die modernen deutschen
panzer bisher verweigert haben sie deine
antwort traum
ja ich schaue mir ja die deutsche
diskussion aus der schweiz an ich finde
sie wie soll ich sagen manchmal
ärgerlich und manchmal exotisch
also wie soll ich sagen deutschland hat
kein problem damit saudi arabien oman
und so weiter mit leopard zu beliefern
im umfang von mehreren hundert stück
zögert aber dasselbe für die ukraine zu
tun fragezeichen warum
wenn sie einmal schauen wie die deutsche
diskussion begonnen hat also mit der
liefern 5000 helme und ein mobiles
feldspital das war der stand im märz
also da kann man sagen da hat sich schon
einiges getan natürlich aber ich habe ab
und zu ja auch ihren sender mal geschaut
und wenn ich mir überlege was was sind
dafür gestalten aufgetreten auch in
ihren größeren talkshows und haben
gesagt naja nun lieber ukraine ist
sondern auch mal zeit zu kapitulieren
und westliche waffenlieferungen das
machen wir nicht das verlängert nur
unnötig das leiden von dem niveau kommen
wir und da hat sich schon viel getan auf
jeden fall
warum warum deutschland das nicht
liefert müssen sie letztlich die
deutsche politik fragen es gibt nationen
in europa die deutlich die die sache
ganz anders ins baltikum polen
selbst ist selbst staaten wie tschechien
oder die slowakei gegeben fast ihr
gesamtes material ab in die ukraine weil
sie sagen ja ich meine was sollen wir
machen mit den systemen helfen wir jetzt
der kleine denn die kann sie brauchen
und dafür werden wir dann zu den
amerikanern ausgestattet und auf dem
neuesten natus standard gebracht das ist
ja eigentlich so diese idee dieser
dieser tausch geschlossen
ich sehe im prinzip keinen grund warum
deutschland nicht dasselbe sagen könnte
weil ich meine also wir wissen wie es um
die einsatzfähigkeit der bundeswehr
bestellt ist und um die einsatzfähigkeit
des materials wenn sie wenn sie jetzt
eine chance haben die komplette armee
auf dem modernen nato standards zu
setzen dann würde ich sagen sollten sie
jetzt ergreifen
hier kommt eine abschließende frage
bleibt auch noch zwei pakete haben wir
heute
gehört der us-verteidigungsminister
außen hat eines verkündet und auch der
us verteidigungs außenminister blinken
der in kiew ist der auch noch mal gesagt
hat 2,2 milliarden
was fällt bei diesen beiden paketen auf
und was soll dieses zweite paket auch
noch einmal konkret umfassen also dieses
dieses zweite paket ist von 22
milliarden dollar das blinken heute
verkündet hat dass besteht wiederum aus
zwei komponenten zu je einer milliarde
eine milliarde sind eigentlich
langfristige finanzhilfen und dienen
dazu die ukraine langfristig mit
material auszustatten das heißt also das
ist eine planung die weit über diesen
krieg hinaus geht ist sondern schon in
richtung künftige weltordnung
beziehungsweise künftige
sicherheitsarchitektur eurasiens also es
ist irrelevant ob die ukraine der nato
beitritt oder nicht sie wird
waffentechnisch auf jeden fall auf nato
standard gebracht und dafür dienen diese
dieses erste paket von einer milliarde
und die zweite milliarde dient dazu die
sicherheitsarchitekturen in osteuropa
vor allem zu stärken also vor allem in
den staaten jetzt nicht so finanzkräftig
sind beispielsweise moldawien rumänien
albanien es sind aber auch schon stärker
militarisierte starten dabei wie zb die
baltischen staaten oder auch
griechenland also man kann sagen es ist
eine gewaltige investition in die
sicherheitsarchitektur osteuropas weil
wir ganz klar sagen müssen es ist
eigentlich es ist klar was wir für ein
russland bekommen werden nach diesem
krieg egal wie er kriegt ausgeht es wird
entweder ein totalitäres russland sein
dass ein ja ein sicherheitsrisiko
darstellen wird für westeuropa oder es
wird ein russland sein dass im zerfall
und der gang über geht mit den gleichen
konsequenzen also wir sehen hier nicht
nur einfach einen krieg in der ukraine
wir sehen hier die künftige ordnung die
sicherheitsarchitektur des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts entstehen
und das ist natürlich spannend dabei zu
sein es ist aber auch traurig weil wir
uns eben verabschieden müssen von ideen
wie wir sie in den nullerjahren mal
gehabt haben dass russland ein
kooperations partner des westens sein
kann der nato gibt es immer dritter des
seat war gesagt russland ist der gegner
und wird es lange bleiben
ausblicke und fazit von markus kreuz von
der eth in zürich herzlichen dank für
ihre zeit heute hier abend heute abend
beim zdf heute live
wir beenden diesen stream auch mit einer
traurigen nachricht aus großbritannien
queen elizabeth die zweite ist im alter
von 96 jahren verstorben das teilte
buckingham palace heute mit wir werden
diesen stream und machen gleich auch
weiter mit einem weiteren stream zum
tode von queen elizabeth der zweite
vielen dank und vielen dank fürs
zuschauen an euch